[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: So
here we are again.
So I'm going to finish real
quick proof of a theorem
that I stated last
time due to Cantor.
So let me recall the setting.
So last time, we
were finishing up
what I had to say about
cardinality, which remember,
is a notion of size of sets.
And at the end,
for a given set A,
then we defined
the power set of A
to be the set of
all subsets of A.
And last time, for example,
we did several of them
or looked at a few
different power sets.
And simplest example is that
the power set of the empty set
is the set containing
the empty set.
In particular, the power
has one more element
than the empty set.
The empty set has no elements.
The power set of the empty
set has one element, namely
the empty set.
And we are looking at this
to answer a question which
I posed at the end of
last class, namely,
all the sets we saw
from the integers
to even numbers to
rational numbers, which
is on the assignment, all
have the same cardinality
as the natural numbers.
And that's what we call
the countably infinite.
And so a question
would be, is there
any set that is
bigger in cardinality
then the natural numbers?
Is there any set
that's uncountable?
And so this theorem due to
Cantor answers that and more.
And it says the following--
if A is any set, so if A is a
set, then the cardinality of A
is strictly smaller than
the cardinality of the power
set of A. And as a consequence
is that the natural numbers
have smaller size than the power
set of the natural numbers,
which has smaller size than
the power set of the power
set of the natural numbers,
which is smaller in size
than-- and so on.
So there are an
infinity of infinities.
There is an infinity
of infinite sizes.
So let's prove this theorem,
and it's extremely clever
and a bit mind boggling.
So first, let me prove
that A has cardinality less
than or equal to the cardinality
of the power set of A.
So let A be a set.
First, we can show that the
cardinality of A is less than
or equal to the cardinality
of the power set of A.
So we need to find an injection,
a one-to-one map from A
into the power set of A. And
the simplest one to choose
is one that takes
an element of A
to the set containing
just that element.
So define f from A
into the power set of A
by the function that takes x.
And this should spit
out a subset of A.
So this will be the subset
that consists solely of x.
And this is clearly one to one.
I'll prove this right now.
Then we need to prove that
if f of x equals f of y,
then x equals y, but this is
clear from the definition.
Then if f of x equals f of y,
this means the set containing
x-- this is by the definition
of how we've defined little f--
means that the set
containing x is
equal to the set containing y.
But this means x equals y.
They both contain one element.
Two sets are equal if
and only if one side
is an element of the other.
That just means x
equals y in the set.
Thus, f is one to
one, which since we
found an injective map from A to
the power set of A this means--
So now we want to show that
they cannot have the same
cardinality.
We now show that A does not
have the same cardinality
as the power set of A. And
these two statements are
what is meant when we write
down, recall the definition,
of the cardinality
of A or size of A
being smaller than the
cardinality of the power
set of A.
So we're going to do this
by a proof by contradiction.
So that means we're
going to assume
that this does not hold and
arrive at a false statement.
So I assume that they do
have the same cardinality.
So this is our
initial assumption.
We're going to derive a false
statement from this assumption.
And the only way to arrive
at a false statement
from a given assumption in a
logically consistent fashion
is that the original statement,
namely this, is false.
In other words, the thing
we want to show is true.
So let's assume they have
the same cardinality.
What does that mean?
Then there exists a bijective
function g going from A
to the power set of A.
Remember, a bijective
function means
that G is one to one and onto.
One to one meaning
different things of A
gets mapped to different
things of the power set.
Onto means everything
in the power set
gets mapped onto from A.
So really, the fact
that it's surjective
is the only thing
I'm going to use.
And I'm going to
define a weird set.
And we're going to
look at this set.
So define a set B. And
this is a subset of A. B
is a set of all x's in A
such that x is not in f of x.
This should be g.
So remember, g maps
from A to the power set.
So for any given x in A,
g of x is a subset of A.
So the condition to be in B
is that this element x is not
in the image of itself by G.
And B could be empty.
There could be no x's
in A that satisfy this.
But it's just a subset of
A, simply by definition.
We're just looking
at elements in A that
satisfy a certain condition.
So since it's a
subset of A, this
means that it's a element
of the power set of A.
This is just how the
power set is defined.
Remember, it's all subsets of A
So B is an element of the
power set of A. Therefore,
something gets mapped
to B under this map.
So since g is surjective,
there exists b in capital A
such that g of little b
equals capital B. So this just
follows from the fact
that g is a surjection,
meaning everything
in here must get
mapped to by some element in A.
But now, let's take
a look at this B guy.
There are two cases--
either b is in g of b
or b is not in g of b.
So b is in g of b.
If b is in g of b, remember
this is equal to capital B,
by definition.
And to be in capital B means
that x is not in g of x.
So let me just write this again.
This means b is in B, which
means b is not in g of b.
We started off
with b and g of b,
and ended with b
is not in g of b.
So we arrive at a false
statement in this case.
Then there's one other case--
b is not in g of b.
Then if b is not in g of b,
this immediately implies,
by the definition of
little b, meaning g of b
is in capital B. So let
me write it this way.
So if b is not in g of b, then
from the definition of capital
B, this implies that b is
in capital B. That's just
from the definition
of capital B.
But now capital B is
equal to g of little b,
which is another contradiction.
Because we started with
this and ended with this.
So what I've really proven is--
so let's ignore this
contradiction mark here--
thus, we have shown that b in
g of b implies b not in g of b.
b not in g of b
implies b is in g of b.
So we've proven the statement
that b is in g of b if
and only if b is not in g of b.
And this is a very
false statement--
cannot have some object being in
the set if and only if it's not
in the set.
So we've arrived at
a false statement.
And therefore, our
initial assumption
which led us there, namely that
the cardinality of the set A
has the same cardinality
as the power set of A,
must have been false.
So it feels almost like you're
being hoodwinked a little bit
with this proof.
But to give you some sort
of cling or connection
back to reality, what's
underlying this argument
or what's one way of
understanding this argument is
to think about--
so in some sense, what
this argument does
is make you talk
about being in B
while having to also
reference B itself.
And maybe this seems a bit wild
because this is a math course,
but you can do the statement
just in the English language.
If I am to tell you
that I am a liar,
then if that statement is
true, then what I just said,
namely that I am
a liar, is false,
which means I'm not a liar.
Therefore, "I am a liar"
implies I'm not a liar.
And vice versa-- if
I say, "I am a liar,"
and that statement
is false, meaning
I'm not a liar, then
that statement is true,
which implies I am a liar.
So of course, I
would not lie to you.
I would just give you
alternative facts.
But that statement
is kind of what's
underlying this argument.
So I'm going to put that
there, true or false.
That's the connection to
these two things, loosely,
or at least the
logic is contained
in trying to verify
this statement.
So that's all I'm going
to say about cardinality.
We're going to move on
to the real numbers now.
And so this is really, like I
said in the previous lecture,
our first real goal of the
class is to describe R. namely,
what exactly is the
set of real numbers?
What characterizes the
And so let me state
this as a theorem
just completely ahead of time,
so that it's there for us.
And this is our goal, although
we're not going to prove it.
Our goal is just to understand
what this theorem says.
So this is a complete
description of what R is.
There exists a unique
ordered field containing Q
with the least upper bound
property, which we denote
by R, instead of real numbers.
So as you sit there and listen
to this, you shouldn't have--
maybe you do, but
you really shouldn't
expect to have any idea
about what this theorem says,
what all these words mean.
So our goal for this lecture is
to make sense of these words.
So the rest you
should understand.
So our goal for this lecture is
to make sense of these words,
"ordered field," "least
upper bound property."
Because these are the two
defining characteristics of R.
And I'm not going to
prove this theorem.
We're just going to
take it as a given.
We could prove this theorem but
it takes quite a bit of time.
And I'd rather start
studying properties of R
than building R. This is
not so uncommon in math,
that one is not especially
interested in the proof
of actually why
certain things exist,
but we are definitely interested
in the properties of that thing
once we know it exists.
So let's get started
on making sense
of what this theorem says.
Let's start off
with ordered stuff.
This has ordered field,
least upper bound property.
Let's start off with
what do I mean by order.
We've seen that just
a little bit already
when we talked about
the natural numbers
and this well-ordered property
of the natural numbers.
But I was just using words
to label a certain property
of the natural numbers.
I didn't say they meant
anything specifically.
It was just a label for that.
But when I say "order" now, this
will definitely mean something.
So ordered sets and
fields definition--
an ordered set is a
set S with a relation,
which we label with
this less than symbol .
And this relation
satisfies two properties.
One is you can always check
whether two elements are bigger
than each other or equal.
So for all x, y in S, either
x equals y, x is less than y,
or that's just restating,
y is less than x.
And if x is less than
y, and y is less than z,
then x is less than z.
So an ordered set is just a
set with some relation which
has two properties,
namely that for any two
elements in the set,
I can compare the two.
That's basically what this says.
And I have this
transitive property
that if x is less than y,
and y is less than z, then
x is less than z.
And so as I said
before, whenever
you have some sort of mildly
interesting definition,
you should definitely
try to come up
with examples and non-examples.
So what's the simplest
example of an ordered set?
Well, the natural
numbers, which we
discussed earlier,
but also the integers,
where I have to define
what this relation means.
We say m is less than n,
this m is less than n,
if n minus m is
a natural number.
So this is how we
define our order.
So n is bigger than m if n
minus m is a natural number.
And you can check that this is
just the usual ordering on z.
And that satisfies
these two properties.
The standard order on Q,
namely that we'll say q
is less than r if there
exist natural numbers, m, n,
such that r minus
q equals m over n.
So these are just
the usual orders
of orderings on the integers
and rational numbers
that you're used to
and that you know.
I'm just writing out exactly
how one would define this order.
And you can check just using
this definition of these orders
that these orders
satisfy 1 and 2.
Now, a simple non-example,
which I guess you could call it
a relation which satisfies 2
but not 1, is the following--
so let's take our set S to be--
and create the power set
of the natural numbers.
And we define a relation A
less than B by A is less than B
if A is a subset of B.
So I'm just defining a
relation on the power set--
A less than B if A
is a subset of B.
And maybe I shouldn't
even use less than,
because this makes you think
that it's automatically
an order.
So let's make it a
script-looking less than.
This relation is not
an order, though.
I keep saying "order,"
so we usually refer
to this relation as an order.
So it's clear that
it satisfies 2.
Why?
Because A is a subset of
B. B is a subset of C.
Then A is a subset of C,
i.e., A is less than C.
It just follows
from the definition
of what it means to be
a subset of the other.
If A is a subset of B, that
means every element of A
is an element of B. If
B's an element of C, that
means every element of
B is an element of C.
And therefore, every element
of A is an element of C.
So this relation satisfies the
second transitive property,
but it doesn't
satisfy the first.
I cannot always measure if one
thing is bigger than the other.
Why is this?
For example, the
set containing 0
does not equal the
set containing 1.
But neither of
these things hold.
So for something to be an order,
or a set to be an ordered set,
it has to have this property
that I can always compare
two elements of the set.
And for this relation,
which seems like it could be
an order-- it satisfies
the second property--
it does not satisfy the first
property because I cannot
always compare two subsets of
the natural numbers by saying
one is a subset of the other.
So we just saw that.
We have two sets
which are not equal,
but one is not bigger
than the other.
And so one more
example, which again, I
will leave for you
to check that it does
satisfy conditions 1 and 2
just based on how it's defined.
For example, this
is the dictionary
ordering of Q Cartesian product
Q. I think I wrote this down.
I mean, you should know
what the Cartesian product
is of two things.
But let me just recall
that I have two sets.
The Cartesian
product of A and B,
this is the set of all
ordered pairs of elements
from those sets.
So the dictionary
ordering of Q is what?
So I need to define
this relation which
I claim is an order.
So we'll say that a, b is less
than q, r if one of two things
happens.
If either a is less
than q or a equals
q, and b is less than r--
so dictionary ordering or
alphabetical ordering of Q.
You can just check and see
which is smaller first.
If they're both equal, then
you check the next letter,
and see which one's
smaller there.
So then this relation
that I've defined here
is in order on Q cross Q,
making it an ordered set.
So this is what
an ordered set is.
We'll get to an ordered
field in just a second.
But now, let me define what
I mean by this least upper
bound property.
And this is really what
sets R apart from Q.
So we'll see in a minute
that both R and Q are ordered
fields, so that's not
what separates R from Q,
the rational numbers.
But what does separate R from
Q is the second property,
the least upper bound property.
So if I removed that
property, and just
said there exists a unique
ordered field containing Q,
that would just be Q. We don't
need to add anything to it.
But it's the second property,
the least upper bound property,
that really separates R from Q.
So to define this,
I need to define
what a least upper bound is.
And this is all in the
setting of an ordered set.
Let S be an ordered set,
and let E be a subset of S.
So I'm going to make a
series of definitions here.
First, if there exists
an element of S--
so not necessarily the set
I'm looking at, the subset
I'm looking at--
such that for all x in E, x
is less than or equal to b.
So here, I have this
order less than.
Less than or equal to means
just what it means in English,
either x is less than
b or x is equal to b,
and the same thing with bigger
than or equal to, and so on.
But just keep in mind
that this ordered
set is a general ordered set.
You could think of it as
the dictionary ordering
on Q cross Q.
So if there exists a b
such that for all x in E,
x is less than or
equal to b, then
we say that E is bounded above.
And this element of b
is an upper bound for E.
So if I can find some element
of my set bigger than everything
in this set E, I say
E's bounded above,
and will be an upper bound.
I also have lower bounds.
If there exists b in S
such that for all x in E,
b is smaller than or
equal to everything in E,
so b is less than or equal to x,
then we say E is bounded below,
and b is a lower bound for E.
So b sits below everything in E.
Now, we call an element in S
the least upper bound for E
if it satisfies two conditions.
One is, if there's
a least upper bound,
there should at least
be an upper bound.
b is an upper
bound for E, and it
should be, in some sense, the
least of all upper bounds.
So if I take any
other upper bound,
b sub 0 should sit
below that one.
So an element is the least
upper bound for a set
E if it's an upper
bound and it's
the least among all
other upper bounds.
It sits below every
other upper bound.
And in this case, we also
say b0 is the supremum of E.
And we write b0
equals sup E. Now,
this was having to
deal with upper bounds.
We can also deal
with lower bounds
or we also have a
definition corresponding
to lower bounds for what would
be the greatest lower bound.
So we call an element of
S the greatest lower bound
for E if two
conditions hold, which
is kind of similar
to the conditions we
had for at least upper bound.
Except now for lower bounds,
b0 is a lower bound for E,
and it is the greatest
of all lower bounds.
If b is any lower
bound for E, then b
is less than or equal to b0.
And so there's some Latin name
attached to least upper bound,
so there's a Latin name attached
to the greatest lower bound,
which we call the infimum.
We also call b0 the infimum
of E. And we write b0
equals inf E.
So we have this mildly
interesting and complex
definition, which means we
should look at some examples
to get a feel for it.
So let's look at
some simple examples.
So let's take our big
ordered set to be Z.
And let's take our set E
to be minus 1, 0, and 2.
So what about this guy?
What is the supremum?
What is the infimum?
So really, if I'm going
to prove or if I'm
going to make a
statement something is
equal to the supremum
or something is
equal to the infimum, I should
actually give a proof of that,
meaning if I say something
is an infimum or something is
a supremum, then I
need to prove that it
satisfies these two conditions
and these two conditions.
But I'm just going
over examples,
so I will not give a
full proof of that.
This is just to get
some intuition going.
So now, first off, what would
be an upper bound for E?
Well, 3, 4, 5--
2 is an upper bound because
2 is bigger than or equal to
everything in the set.
So 2, 3, 4, 5--
these are all upper
bounds for this set E.
But what is the supremum,
meaning the least upper bound?
That would be 2.
If I take anything less
than 2 that's not an upper
bound because there's something
in the set bigger than that.
And if I take anything
bigger than that,
then this is going
to be bigger than 2,
but 2 is still an upper bound.
So 2 is the least upper bound.
Now what about lower bounds?
A lower bound would be minus
1, because minus 1 is less than
or equal to
everything in the set.
But then so would be minus
2, minus 3, and so on.
But the greatest lower
bound would be minus 1.
Now let's do another example.
Let's now look at S,
the rational numbers,
and let's take E to be a
set of rational numbers such
that 0 is bigger
than or equal to--
Q is between 0 and 1 inclusive.
So then what are
some upper bounds?
Everything in E is less
than or equal to 1.
So 1 is also a perfectly good
upper bound, 3/2, 5/4, 6/5,
7/6.
Anything bigger
than or equal to 1
is also an upper
bound for this set.
And the least upper
bound would be 1.
So if I were to try to
draw Q for this set--
let's not do that--
I usually draw this line is
for the real number line,
but let's imagine
it's Q. So everything
bigger than or equal to 1
sits above everything in E.
So everything bigger than or
equal to 1 is an upper bound,
and the least upper bound is 1.
What are some lower bounds?
Everything in the set E is
bigger than or equal to 0.
So 0 is a lower bound.
So is minus 1/2, minus 1/3,
minus 1/4, minus 1/5, and so
on.
But anything less than or
equal to 0 is a lower bound.
Nothing bigger than 0
can be a lower bound
because I can always find some--
so this is not a proof, but
this is some explanation.
Maybe I should
have also said this
for the upper bound statement,
but anything bigger than 0
is not a lower bound.
Because what if I take
some number, call it r,
bigger than 0, and less than 1,
then r cannot be a lower bound
because I can find something in
E less than r, namely r over 2.
So therefore-- and we're
going to do some proofs where
we actually have to
get our hands dirty
and prove something is an
infimum or the supremum.
So you'll see how that
works, but for now, let's
just go off of intuition.
The infimum of this set is 0.
Now, both of these
examples so far
have this property that
both the sup and the inf
belong to the set E
that I'm looking at.
But this is not necessarily
always the case.
So I could change this
slightly so our universe,
the ordered set we're
looking in, is still Q,
and the subset E is now,
let's say, q is bigger than 0
and less than 1.
Then sup of E is
still going to be 1,
but this is not an
element of this set E.
It's of course an element of
S, this universe we're in,
but it's not an
element of the set E.
And likewise, the
infimum is still 0,
but it's not an element of E.
So there are
situations where you
have a set, a subset
of an ordered set,
which has an infimum
and supremum which
do not exist in this smaller
set you're looking at.
Whether or not the
supremum or infimum
may exist in the
universe that you're
looking at in the bigger set
is an entirely different issue.
In fact, that's the next issue
we're going to talk about.
So let me just reiterate
what we saw a minute ago.
So we can be in some
ordered set Z or Q,
and the smaller set, which
we're taking the inf or sup in,
it could belong to
the smaller set--
for example, in this case
1 and 0 were in the set E--
or not.
There is this case where
neither of them were in E.
And of course, if I put
less than or equal to here,
then I would had the inf
in E and the sup not in E,
and then vice versa.
So inf's and sup's of these
sets don't necessarily
need to belong to that
set you're looking at.
But they at least
existed in the big set Q.
Now, big, ordered sets--
so this ordered set that has
this property that the inf
and sup of bounded
above and below sets
exist in the bigger set always--
is what we call an ordered
set with the least upper
bound property.
So the definition--
ordered set S
has the least property if
every subset of S which
is non-empty and bounded
above has a supremum in S.
So a set has the least
upper bound property
if every non-empty bounded
set has a supremum.
And so we could come
up with simple examples
of sets that do have the
least upper bound property.
For example, let's
take S to be--
I mean, this is kind
of the simplest one--
S with a single
element, let's say 0.
Here there's no
order to put on it.
Every element in here
is equal to itself.
And therefore, every
non-empty subset of S
is just the whole
set, and the supremum
would then be that one element.
So this is kind of the
silliest one you could do.
Let's say you could
have two elements.
And then if E is a subset
of S, E is one of four guys.
If E is a non-empty subset
of S here, the order is 1,
0 is less than 1.
If E is equal to 0,
then sup equals 0.
If E is equal to
1, sup E equals 1.
And if E is equal to 0, 1,
this implies sup E equals 1.
So this is in S, this
is in S, this is in S.
So every subset of S which is
non-empty has a supremum in S.
So these are not the
most interesting examples
of sets with this least
upper bound property.
So for example, maybe
a more interesting one
would be if I take S to be,
let's say, with the dots here,
minus 3, minus 2, minus 1.
So let me just
write it this way--
minus 1, minus 2, minus
3, minus 4, and so on,
with the usual ordering
coming from the integers.
So minus 2 is less than minus
1, minus 3 is less than minus 2,
and so on.
I claim this that does have
the least upper bound property.
Why?
Because if E is a subset
of S, E non-empty.
In fact, both of these--
this was always bounded
above because there's
only two elements.
And you can choose
the biggest one, 1.
Every subset of S is also
bounded above by minus 1.
So every subset of S is
automatically bounded above.
So I just need to check
that every non-empty set has
a supremum in S. If E is a
subset of S and is non-empty,
then let me look at the set
minus E. This is a label.
This is not meant to
mean anything always.
This is a label, which is
the set of elements minus x.
So I take all my
elements in E, which
is a subset of the
negative integers.
I take their minuses.
This is now a subset
of the natural numbers.
And since by the
well-ordering property
of the natural numbers,
there exists an element
in minus E such that it
sits below everything
in minus E for all x in E,
which means that for all x in E,
x is less than or
equal to minus m.
And I'll let you think about
this just for a minute.
But so m is in minus E,
therefore minus m is in E.
And m less than or
equal to minus x
for all x in E implies that for
all x in capital E is less than
or equal to minus m.
And therefore, I found
an element actually
in the set capital
E that's bigger
than or equal to
everything in the set.
You can convince
yourself or write down
a formal proof, if you like,
that this implies that minus
m is therefore the supremum.
And so using this
trickery of going from one
set that's bounded above to
a different set, a subset
of the natural numbers, you
can also show, for example,
Z has the least
upper bound property,
which I'm going to now
shorten because those
are a lot of things to write.
LUBP, least upper
bound property--
the integers also
have this property.
But the integers are not
all that interesting, again,
because I cannot divide by an
integer and stay in the set.
For what we want to do, we want
to be able to add, multiply,
subtract, and divide.
And we can't do that
in the integers.
We can do that in
the rational numbers.
However, Q does not
have this property.
And we're going to prove this.
So this is what we're going to
prove in a couple of theorems
here, but let me just
put this out in front.
Q does not have the least
upper bound property.
And where does this come from?
This comes from the simple fact
which if you believe your--
I don't want to call
it Greek mythology,
but maybe it's Greek
mythology strictly speaking--
that some young guy discovered
that the square root of 2
is not a rational number and
then he got thrown off a cliff.
That's who we have to
thank for showing us
that Q is not
perfect, that it does
have this algebraic property
which I just referenced--
the fact that you can
add, subtract, multiply,
and divide and stay
within the set.
But it does not have square
roots of prime numbers,
but square root of 2 in it.
And this then manifests
itself in this least
upper bound property by giving
an example of a set which
is bounded above which does not
have a supremum in the set Q.
So basically, if E is the
set of rational numbers--
I have not stated a theorem
yet, but I'm just telling you
what we're about to do--
if E is the subset
of rational numbers
where positive and q
squared is less than 2,
then sup E does not exist
in the rational numbers.
So therefore, we
would have found
a set which is
bounded above which
does not have a supremum
in the rational numbers.
And therefore, the
rational numbers
do not have the least
upper bound property.
So this is what
we're going to do.
And I'll prove-- state
a couple of theorems
that spell all this out.
So first, I'm going to
prove a theorem about a what
the supremum of such a
set would have to satisfy.
So if x is in Q--
this is a statement
of a theorem--
if x is in Q, and if x equals
the supremum of the set,
then x is bigger than or equal
to 1, and x squared equals 2.
So we're just saying--
don't try to take this as
necessarily contradicting what
I wrote there because that was
not a statement of a theorem
yet.
I'm stating this theorem that
if I have such a supremum in Q
of the set, then it would
have to square and give me 2.
I'm not saying such
an element exists.
I'm just saying if there
is any element of Q that
is the supremum
of this set, then
it has to be bigger than or
equal to 1, and it squares 2.
So let's give a proof of this.
And because I don't want to
keep writing the set again,
so I'm going to use the notation
that I used in the comments.
Let E be the set that
I'm interested in.
So this should be--
and suppose we have
an element of Q
which is the supremum of E.
So first off, what would
be one element of E?
What's one rational number
whose square is less than 2?
1.
So since 1 is in E,
square is less than 2,
and x is the supremum
of E, meaning
it's an upper bound
for E, it must
be bigger than or equal
to everything an E,
in particular for 1.
That implies x is bigger
than or equal to 1.
So that's the first part of
the theorem I want to prove.
So now we're going to
prove two inequalities
to show that x squared
is actually equal to 2.
We're going to prove--
so this is a common
trick in analysis,
that if I have two
things that I would
like to show equal to each
other, sometimes a way
to show that is by showing one
is less than or equal to that.
And this is less than
or equal to that.
So one side is less than
or equal to the other side
and vice versa, which
immediately implies
they must equal each other.
So that's what
we're going to do.
And we're going to now
prove that x squared
is bigger than or equal to 2.
We'll then prove that x squared
is less than or equal to 2,
and therefore, x
squared equals 2.
So to do this, we'll do
this by contradiction.
So let's assume-- everything
else we've done so far
is still true, but now we
want to prove this statement.
So we're going to assume
that this statement is false.
I assume that x
squared is less than 2.
So we'll define a certain
rational number, h,
which is a smaller of
two rational numbers.
It's going to be the
smaller of 1/2 and 2
minus x squared over
2 over 2x plus 1.
And let me just reiterate
this is less than 1
because it's the smaller
of 1/2 and this number.
Now, when you write a
proof, as you'll see,
it's going to be
magic that somehow
this h does something magical.
That's not exactly how
you come up with proofs.
How it comes up is
you take an inequality
that you want to mess with,
you fiddle around with it,
and you see that if h
is given by something,
then it breaks the
inequality or it
satisfies the inequality,
which whichever one you're
trying to do.
So since x squared is less
than 2, h is positive.
It's the minimum of a
1/2 and this number.
So if it's a 1/2, it's positive.
If it's this one, then
it's still positive.
And what I'm going to
prove now is that x plus h
is in E. Its square
is less than 2.
This will give us
our contradiction,
because x is supposed to
be an upper bound for E,
and therefore, x is
supposed to be bigger
than or equal to x plus h.
But this is x plus
a positive number.
x plus a positive
number is bigger than x.
So how do we do this?
We have to compute the square of
this and show it's less than 2.
And that's where our
choice of h comes from.
We compute that x
plus h squared--
this is x squared plus
2xh plus h squared--
now this is less than x
squared plus 2xh plus h.
Why?
Because h times h is less
than h since h is less than 1.
So this is why we chose
h to be less than 1,
so that I can get
rid of this square,
and somehow just have a
single h floating around,
which I can then use to
show x plus h is in E.
So when I write the
string of inequalities,
this thing is supposed to
be equal to the next thing.
This is not saying x plus
h squared is equal to what
I'm about to write now.
So this is equal to x squared
plus 2x plus 1 times h.
Now, h is the minimum
of these two numbers.
So h is going to be smaller
than or equal to this thing.
And so this is 2 minus
x squared over 2.
Write it this way, so I
had what I had before.
And then times 2 minus x
squared over 2, 2x plus 1.
So now some magic is happening.
This cancels with that.
And I have 2 minus x squared
over 2, which is less than 2
minus x squared, so
less than x squared
plus 2 minus x squared, because
I took a 1/2 of it, equals 2.
So summarizing, we started
off with x plus h squared,
and we showed it
was less than 2.
And therefore, x plus h is in E.
But if I have an element of E--
let's see where are we on space.
But I have an element of
E which is bigger than x.
So that implies that x is
not equal to the supremum
of the set.
Remember by definition,
something is the supremum
if it's an upper
bound for the set.
Something's not an upper bound
if you can find something
in the set bigger than b0.
And this is also a
good exercise to do
when you come across
a new definition,
is to try and negate
it to understand
it a little bit better.
So let me write here next to
b is an upper bound for E--
let me write what this
means, actually, here.
Let me write this here.
b0 is not-- so what's the
negation of being an upper
bound--
so not an upper bound for
E if there exists an x in E
such that x is bigger than b0.
So we have found an element--
so going back to
our proof, we have
found an element
of our set E which
is bigger than x, which
means that x is not
the supremum of E,
which is a contradiction
to our assumption.
These are assumptions
for the theorem.
So we're always assuming this.
So this is a contradiction.
Thus our assumption
that x squared
is bigger than or equal to 2--
I mean less than 2, which is
different from our assumptions
of the theorem, is false.
So now, we want to prove
that x squared equals 2.
So we now show x
squared equals 2.
Since x squared-- so this
is not exactly the proof.
Just I'm going to rewrite
it a little differently
so it's maybe clear that instead
of showing also x squared is
less than or equal to 2, which
we know the less than cannot
happen, let's just show that x
squared cannot be bigger than
2.
Since x squared is bigger
than or equal to 2,
this means either
x squared equals 2,
which we want to show, or
x squared is bigger than 2.
So let's rule out this case.
We now show that the case x
squared bigger than 2 cannot
hold.
So suppose otherwise.
We're going to do
this-- this is going
to be a proof by
contradiction, as well.
I guess when I say x squared
bigger than 2 cannot hold,
I'm also saying x squared must
be less than or equal to 2.
But anyway, so let's
show this cannot hold.
So we're going to do this
by contradiction, as well.
So we're trying to
show this cannot hold.
So let's assume
that it does hold.
So that's the
negation of what we
want to show, which
is this statement,
that x squared greater
than 2 does not hold.
So assume x squared
is bigger than 2.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to find an upper
bound for the set
E which is strictly
smaller than x.
And we have to do that
next time because I think
I'm about to run out of time.
So I hate to stop
the proof here,
but we'll finish this
in the next lecture.